aquí en nariño Carlos está acostumbrado
a conseguir un buen precio por sus
turrones de pasta de coca una mezcla de
hojas de coca cultivadas y productos
químicos que se utiliza para fabricar la
base de la cocaína pero Lleva más de un
mes sin encontrar comprador debido al
colapso de la industria de la cocaína y
ahora se ha quedado con más de 8
kilogramos de este producto
Colombia es el primer productor mundial
de cocaína y tanto para Carlos como para
el 1,5% de la población del país subida
depende de este cultivo según los
expertos y las autoridades la razón de
este declive de la economía de la droga
se debe a la sobreproducción de la hoja
de coca y al aumento de opiáceo
sintéticos como el fentanilo
es probable que la baja demanda por
pasta de coca en algunas regiones de
Colombia
tenga que ver
aún hay que estudiar lo más
profundamente
con el hecho de que los norteamericanos
han cambiado sus consumos sus gustos el
presidente dijo que el trabajo de las
asambleas de campesinos con su gobierno
son prioritarios para implementar la
sustitución de tierras y los programas
de cultivo agroindustriales según
Gustavo Petro sería la solución para
superar la situación que está dejando
hambrientos a muchos colombianos el año
pasado un informe de la ONU reveló que
el cultivo de coca en Colombia se había
expandido en un 43% alcanzando la enorme
cifra de 204 mil hectáreas la cifra más
alta jamás observada por la oficina de
las Naciones Unidas contra la droga y el
delito